renouveler sa carte d'identité ou son
passeport un véritable parcours du
combattant c'est le cas notamment à la
mairie de montigny le bretonneux les
possibilités de prise de rendez vous sur
internet sont très rares et les dix
agents des affaires générales sont
mobilisés au quotidien face à cette
hausse très importante des demandes
depuis qu'on a repris après le
confinement de déconfinement la série
est vraiment complet tous les jours on a
énormément de demandes des appels
téléphoniques et des demandes urgentes
va embaucher une personne pour augmenter
nos capacités d'accueil mais les
problèmes ça se fait pas comme ça
rapidement parce qu'il faut une
formation il faut que ce soit
agréé par la préfecture parce que ça
touche la société nationale d'après les
estimations deux fois plus de cartes
d'identité de passeports seront délivrés
en 2022 par rapport à 2020 c'est aussi
une hausse de 1000 documents délivrés
par rapport à 2019 les délais peuvent
être allongée pour les usagers j'ai
peut-être un petit peu de chances que ça
s'est fait plutôt assez vite j'ai pris
mon petit rendez vous sur internet et ça
a très bien fonctionné donc ça a été
relativement stable avec la peine trois
semaines je suis venu retirer mon
passeport et voilà j'ai fait la démarche
il ya quand même un certain temps j'ai
eu beaucoup de mal à obtenir
un rendez vous pour déposer ma demande
de passeport et puis après il ya une pad
dans un délai d'à-peu-près 3 4 semaines
pour que je puisse venir le récupérer un
mois pour obtenir sa pièce d'identité
après le dépôt de la demande en mairie
c'est le délai moyen dans les yvelines
les dossiers sont ensuite traitées par
le centre d'expertisé et de ressources
des titres à la préfecture des yvelines
trente agents instructeur vérifie les
pièces et les informations concernées
par les demandes près de 6500 demande
yvelinois sont reçus en préfecture
chaque semaine en 2020 on a eues sur
l'année de 190000 demande en 2021 3 178
milles et rien que sur les quatre
premiers mois de l'année nous sommes
déjà à 178 1000 demandes reçues les
agents du cert sont volontaires par
exemple pour faire des samedis
travaillés donc en plus de leur temps de
travail pour renforcer les équipes de la
préfecture trois agents contractuels ont
été recrutés au mois de mai 2022